[Musique]
ce n'est pas un couteau c'est un couteau c'est
moi
Brian Dundee vraiment ouais vraiment
comment continuez-vous à dire vraiment dessiner leur
puissance rien à voir ici mec juste obtenir
l'ombre propre avec ma merde - Barry
tu sais quand ton père l'a fait il  était-
il moqueur et bien mon père m'a dit
à ce sujet qu'il était juste comme ouais je viens juste d'
arriver et tu as bien fait ça je
ne pense pas que tu puisses te voir d'
ici pas beaucoup de Crocs ici
hein c'est 37 000  des kilomètres de
belle plage immaculée Mike saviez-vous que l'
Australie produit certains des meilleurs vins
du monde entier
non je suis mort je ne savais pas que
beaucoup
attends attends ce n'est pas un film non c'est une
publicité touristique pour l'Australie oui mais écoute
à vous le meilleur Crocodile Dundee depuis
Crocodile Dundee vraiment oui vraiment et
nous avons eu le meilleur voyage de tous les temps, n'est-ce pas,
c'était plutôt sympa
[Musique]
film c'est une partie
Hey
[Musique]
aujourd'hui  les perdants seront la rosette technologique
Brian Dundee ouais vraiment ouais vraiment
je pense que tu dis vraiment qu'est-ce que tu
veux dire par des jours perdus dans l'arrière-pays, il est
l'autre personne ne parle de Mick comme
ça définitivement ce couteau pourrait crier le
travail bien à quel point
tu veux dire cet outil  tu as déjà vu une
baleine à bosse accoucher d'un bain de sang
parle-moi petit gars eh bien mon père
m'en a parlé il était juste comme ouais je
viens d'arriver et tu as fait ça d'accord je
ne pense pas que tu puisses te voir
d'ici
je  ne fais pas que sur ce journal, mon fils, je suis dans
ce pays et les crétins vont apprendre qui est
l'animal le plus dangereux d'Australie,
c'est moi
quoi que ce soit
wombat